الاموال الايرانيه المجمده في الخارج ورقه
ضغط امريكي على ايران واي تحرك بشانها يعد
اشاره الى ان شيئا ما يحصل بين واشنطن
وطهران رئيس الغرفه الايرانيه العراقيه
يحيى الاسحاق اعلن افراج العراق عن اكثر
من مليارين وسبع مئه مليون دولار تزامنا
مع ذلك تعلن الخارجيه العراقيه عن التوصل
الى ترتيبات جوهريه بشان المستحقات
الماليه بين العراق وايران خلال اللقاء
الذي جمع وزير الخارج العراقي فؤاد حسين
ونظيره الامريكي في السعوديه
الخارجيه العراقيه اشارت الى ان فؤاد حسين
اجرى تنسيقا عاليا مع ناظره العماني لغرض
نفسه يؤكد كلام الخارجيه العراقيه ان
لعمان دورا فيما يجري بشان الاموال
المجمده وكاله اسنا ووسائل اعلام ايرانيه
اخرى كانت قد افادت ان زياره سلطان عمان
هيثم بن طارق لطهران في مايو الماضي حققت
اختراقا بهذا الخصوص وتحدثت عن بالافراج
عن نحو 24 مليارا من الاموال المجمده في
الخارج خصوصا من العراق وكوريا الجنوبيه
والبنك الدولي والملاحظ انه بعد ثلاثه
ايام من زياره سلطان عمان لطهران زار
مستشار الرئيس الامريكي مسقط تاتي هذه
التطورات في وقت تحدثت فيه وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه عن محادثات غير مباشره بين
مسؤولين كبار من ايران والولايات المتحده
في عمان الشهر الماضي وتوقعت قرب التوصل
الى اتفاق النووي مؤقت لكن طهران و واشنطن
نفث قرب التوصل لهذا الاتفاق
الاموال المجمده جزءا من اي تسويه محتمله
لا يعرف بالتحديد حجم هذه الاموال
الموجوده في العراق الذي يستورد الغاز
والكهرباء من ايران بالاضافه الى كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان ودول اخرى مع مستحقات
ايران لدى البنك الدولي في عام 2021 كشفت
وكاله الانباء الايرانيه عن الافراج عن
ثلاثه مليارات وخمسمائه مليون دولار دون
ان تحدد من افرج عنها وافرجت بريطانيا عن
530 مليون دولار مقابل اطلاق ايران صراحه
مواطنه ايرانيه بريطانيه وفي 2022 اعلن عن
اخراج العراق عن مليار وستمائه مليون
دولار وتبقى التطورات المرتبطه بهذه
الاموال المجمده احد اهم المؤشرات على
اتجاه العلاقات الايرانيه الامريكيه